the highly anticipated wedding of
Britain's Prince Harry and American
actress Megan Markel is us in one month
away May 19th is a date tonight we'll
take a close look at the life of the
future royal and the CBS News special
we're calling it Meg and Markel American
princess
we spoke to those who know Meg and
Markel the best including four former
sorority sisters and the actor who
played her dad on the TV show suits the
royal stage is said right here at
Windsor Castle
they'll be announced the engagement
operatory and megan muffled
congratulations it's a wonderful
fairytale it's someone from a different
country different background marrying
into our war family when you look at
Megan Markel how do you complete this
sentence Megan Markel is a rock star
friend an intimate look at Megan Markel
from people who know her best and know
why a blind date was all it took
I was beautifully surprised when I
walked into that room and saw her and I
came up and effortlessly so maybe
frustratingly she's gonna be a princess
and I'm trying to kind of go working
with her was great dad
what are you doing here she's a lovely
lovely actress so you got me on my piece
and QS kept me on my toes
I think she's something spectacular it's
an it factor with an approach ability
she's just kind of the perfect package
the total package
she's worldly she cares about things
outside of herself and smart her friends
were certainly on to something because
Megan Markel will indeed become Her
Royal Highness
when she walks down the aisle here in
st. George's Chapel he got on one knee
an instant yes from you yes from the
Queen on down the entire royal family
has embraced this vibrant hopeful couple
wait a minute
absolutely true for me personally I hope
it means these days
what I worry about is that royal family
is not gonna be able to deal with this
dynamo who's walked into their midst
Megan Markel she's divorced biracial
she's an actress everything that could
have gotten you beheaded you know five
hundred years ago that's why this
engagement this marriage has already
brought the monarchy well into the 21st
century when I was growing up it was
unthinkable that there'd be a person of
color in the royal family and so I
welcome this these two are going to be
the premier global philanthropists in
the world yep you can watch the CBS News
special we're calling it Megan Markel
American princess that's tonight at ten
o'clock
nine central right here on CBS we were
in England last week just hanging out at
Windsor Castle where they are going to
get where they're going to tie the knot
and we'll go back again for the wedding
but I think most people are so excited
except the guy at the passport counter
we were checking in so he was excited as
we are about the wedding he goes now you
Americans make such a big deal about
this it's the same day as a football
championship I'm so he was a cranky
Yankee most people are very resided
about the wedding I'm excited Kearney
too excited to see your special tonight
oh thanks yeah yeah looks terrific yeah